and the Oscar goes to
Catherine Martin and Angus strathy for
Moulin Rouge
we would like to thank the academy this
award represents thousands of man hours
of delicate but nonetheless
back-breaking work of over a hundred of
our colleagues and countrymen we thank
them all and to the extraordinary
baslerman who has got us up here who
cares as much about the embroidery
detail on a Can-Can skirt as he does
about lens size or dialogue it was your
vision this is your Oscar Bears we would
also like to thank the best cabojo
supervisor I think anybody could hope
for in Eliza godman
the beautiful pictures of Don McAlpine
thank you to The Marvelous hair and
makeup of Aldo Maurizio and Leslie and
their teams we'd like to also thank the
continual love and support of our family
friends and loved ones I'll be eternally
grateful for the joy given by this girl
and our best lemon thank you
[Applause]
[Music]